hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game from the ongoing vergani
cup it's the legend the nigel short
versus 18 year old bulgarian
woman grandmaster and international
master nurio salimova a lot of you guys
have requested this game and for good
reasons it's it's a very enjoyable one
uh so let's dive straight into it and
see what happened here uh nigel with the
white pieces opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening as well uh what else
would he go for we have knight to f6
knight to f3 and now g6 uh we have
knight to c3 and bishop to g7
we have e4 now uh um that's kind of a
known variation where black plays e5 and
now
white can capture this e5 pawn so here
knight captures an e5 and usually you
can just capture here and open up an
attack from your bishop to the knight
but here uh salimova castles and now uh
again our common moves here are d3 you
could go back with the knight knight to
f3 but here we have bishop to e2 nigel
prepares the castle and now again not
knight captures on e4 but first rook to
e8 we're going to develop our pieces the
white king is still in the center so
nigel will have to
waste the move on castling and then
we're gonna
grab our pawn back so here d4 defending
the knight and the d6 much like you
would in a petrov defense knight to f3
and now knight captures any for finally
winning the pawn back and uh up until
this point it was known territory there
is even a game from 2018 world rapid
championship between even charity and
marcus raga uh where knight captures and
e4 was played but here nigel castles and
it is now as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see uh
what happens knight to c6 not going for
knight captures on c3 and now nigel
could capture on e4 and this is even
fine for white but for example
knight captures rook captures we're
going to attack the queen and now even
bishop to f6 and it will be hard for
white to claim any advantage here uh
your your d for pawn is hanging so you
either have to uh capture on uh
on f6 or go back with bishop to e3 so
it's not it's not a lot so here h3 by
nigel now knight captures on c3b
captures and bishop to f5 nicely
developing the the bishops we have
bishop to e3 and now queen to d7
developing the queen connecting the
works also putting a lot of pressure on
that h3 pawn so rook to e1 nigel
continues developing and now knight to
a5 at some point you want to strike in
the center with c5 uh probably b6 or c5
or maybe a6 and then continuing with
something like that so here rook to c1
and now uh we have a6 and now knight to
d2
so uh how do you wanna uh
continue playing this you could bring
your knights to the f2 to f1 and then
bring it to g3 but nigel is actually
preparing pawn to g4 and then the knight
will be remaneuvered maybe to g3 so rook
a to b8 and now a4 not allowing b5 we
have bishop to e4
nicely grabbing hold of this along
diagonal and offering this bishop here
and while you could capture this for
example captures captures in bishop to
d3 again it's not all that much for
white so nigel
looks
for advantage in in other ways and he
doesn't want to trade off uh unnecessary
material or rather uh
unnecessarily trade-off material so here
d5 grabbing more space in the center and
now queen back to d8 and here queen will
be uh very very useful you can shift the
queen over to h4 also once the c pawn is
pushed you will be also defending that
knight here if the bishop ever leaves
the control of the g5 square even queen
to g5 is possible so a lot of ideas here
we have g4 by nigel as planned and now
c6 finally we strike against the white's
strong center and now knight to f1 uh we
have c captures on d5c captures on d5
and now rook the c8 and this rook the c8
is already at the beginning of a most
interesting game here black could just
continue rook e5 for example you attack
the pawn then you have to defend it with
c4 and then maybe queen h4 comes into
the game
but instead we have rook to c8
completely disregarding that white can
play f3 and trap the bishop here uh but
that's kind of
salimo's plan so here we have f3 nigel
goes after the bishop
and now bishop captures on c3 attacks
the rook on e1 we have f captures on e4
now bishop captures on e1 rook captures
on c8 and now queen captures on c8 and
now queen captures an e1 and now after
all is said and done uh you can see that
salimo has a rook but nigel has the
bishop pair for the rook and it doesn't
seem like like a fair trade also the
knight is hanging but as you'll see it's
not that easy to play this with white so
here at knight to c4 as the knight was
hanging on a5 we were attacking the e3
bishop here and what do you play uh well
also the e4 pawn is hanging so what can
white play it here it's a it's a very
difficult position where if white wants
to keep his advantage he has to go
bishop
back to f2 point is after you give up
the the e4 pawn you have to play knight
to g3 chase away the rook and once the
rook moves you play bishop to d4 and now
with control of this dark square
diagonal you're gonna somehow maybe get
the queen into the attack white will
always have this pressure and black will
always have to be very very careful
however nigel decided that as he's
already up material he might as well
just trade down even further bishop
captures queen captures now the e4 pawn
is still hanging and now knight to d2
this is how he defends the pawn and now
queen to d3 so if you compare this
position to the one that we've discussed
after bishop to f2
here it's not so pleasant for the white
king now you can't really move your
pieces all that much because it's very
easy for black to get his uh well other
uh uh the only other piece into the game
for example rook the ca the rook can
come to d two if the queen moves the
back rank you can even play rook to c1
so it's not going to be easy for white
white is better here but if you play a
perfect uh perfect move so here king to
h2
and b5 of course this is our other
advantage we have uh the possibility of
creating a past b pawn so of course
we're gonna do this a captures on b5 a
captures on b5 and now queen to f2
trying to grab hold maybe of this
diagonal but it's not going to be easy
uh with such a weak king so here rook
the c8 as we said it's very easy to
bring the rook into the game now the
rook can come to c2 to c1 to c3 all
depending on what white plays we have
king to g2 by nigel and now you could
continue pushing your past b pawn but
first rook the c3 now attacking the the
bishop here so nigel defends it with the
king and now b4 continuing to advance
the past b pawn and even though white
has two pieces for a rook his position
is now terrible
you can't really move anything and it's
hard to even well decide on a move here
so nigel tries uh trading off the queens
which is a good idea but uh
salimba decides against it and there is
a brilliant move here queen to d4 uh
just getting the queen out of the way of
course the bishop cannot capture the
queen and now you are ready to continue
pushing your past pawn so king f2
unfinning preparing to capture the queen
now queen e5 preparing queen to h to
check
uh and here nigel plays king to g2 uh
which uh doesn't really hold the
position knight to f3 is a bit more
resilient but still after queen captures
on e4 it's a it's an ugly position to
play so instead after queen e5 we have
king to g2 and now comes b3 of course we
continue pushing our pass pawn queen to
f2 still hoping for some bishop to d4
ideas but now rook to d3 not allowing
any counter play uh we bishop the h6 uh
nigel finds a tricky tricky way to play
this he wants to play a queen to b6 and
with the bishop guarding g7 and f8 uh he
wants to have some pressure against the
the weak black king and hopefully he
will be able to
uh to
not lose this game so here b2 the past
pawn continues advancing and now comes
queen to b6 very nicely done
guarding the b1 square also threatening
queen to b8 queen to d8 both will result
in checkmate so it's very hard for for
black to continue playing this unless
you find the only winning move uh so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for
salimova while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
brilliant idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course rook captures on d2 with check
that's the good stuff
uh this of course we have to move with
tempo because if we allow white even one
move then we are getting checkmated so
this comes with check but also it means
that we have to give up our rook so
bishop captures uh rook and d2 you can't
move the king if you move the king to
still hope
you know have some hopes of checkmating
the black king we just bring a queen
into the game and now after the black
the white queen moves now we play queen
f6 check and we just check mate the
uh the white king uh so instead after
rook capture sunday to check we have
bishop capture sunday two nigel has to
waste the move grabbing the rook and now
comes queen captures an e4 with check
now we're guarding the queening square
and we are you know just uh
really enjoying life so king to f2 uh
and now of course not b1 queen i hope uh
you guys weren't thinking about this
because if you play b1 queen uh then
queen to d8 check and it's uh very very
unpleasant for black king g7 bishop c3
check and what do you play if you play
king h6 queen to h4 is checkmate so you
don't want to blunder away the game like
this so you have to play queen to e5 you
have to give up your queen and then for
example uh
bishop captures on e5 d captures and now
let's say we play d6 and now white has a
very very strong pass pawn on d6 already
and you will not be well you are up a
pawn but it's very unlikely that you'll
you'll be winning this game so instead
after this um
uh king to f2 move uh not b1 but rather
queen to c2 this is again the only
winning move uh and after queen to c2 it
was in this position on move 39 that
nigel short resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
really a wonderful wonderful move or
rather a wonderful series of moves uh
that completely crushed nigel he he
always found that one plan that could
save him but salimo just played
everything perfectly and was able to
take down a very strong grand master
like nigel
and here you resign because once you
deliver one check it doesn't really
matter which one king g7 there are no
moves for for white uh you you can't
move the bishop if you could move the
bishop then well that'd be a little bit
better
but unfortunately you can't the bishop
is pinned also you're just bringing a
queen into the game so there's no move
white can play here if king e3 for
example we're just gonna play b1 queen
we have two queens and we don't care
anymore
uh so yeah uh brilliant brilliant game
by nuril salimova taking down such a
strong player and she's also having a
great tournament she faced uh five grand
master so far she defeated two drew two
and only lost one to uh han smoke and
eman so having a great event so far
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and again thank you for
suggesting such a such a wonderful game
i i would like to thank dylan holloway
pat koppinger mother imam global tennis
network and duras press for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and on everything else that happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day